Any reading tips for becoming teachers who don't want to be corrupted by the
current teacher education at the universities?
Well,
I would say,
you know,
you can,
I have a reading list on my book,
on my website,
Jordan B peterson.com you could go look there.
I'm going to add some more books to read as much classic literature as you can
read history,
like going to the libraries and,
and,
and look at great books,
programs.
That's what I would say.
And you have to educate yourself at the university,
you know,
I mean,
that's always been the case and it's even more the case now is,
is,
uh,
go back and go back and read great literature,
Great Philosophy,
great thinkers,
and you'll learn a tremendous amount that way.
And I think otherwise,
there's no way you couldn't avoid being corrupted by the current teacher
education at universities.
The education faculties are absolutely dreadful.
Absolutely dreadful.
So,
okay.